the left loves to pretend they care
about the poor while demonizing the rich
and then putting in policies that just
exacerbate that situation here is
congresswoman pramila jayapal and she's
just had it with those rich people and
she wants their money we have proven
with the child tax credit with survival
checks with so many provisions of the
American Rescue plan that poverty is a
bad policy Choice it is a choice and we
can make different choices that is the
good news my ultra millionaire Tax Act
which I'm proud to lead with my friend
Senator Elizabeth Warren would narrow
the racial wealth Gap help level the
playing field and ensure that the
wealthiest Among Us finally pay their
fair share just imagine what we could do
with the money that it would raise this
would be unprecedented investments in
health care in Universal child care in
education in transitioning to a
renewable energy economy in affordable
housing so that people could live and
wake up every day knowing that they were
able to provide for their families that
the Next Generation would do better than
our generation for way too long our
society has been rigged to favor the
wealthy this is a solution that would
give average people a fair Shake
you know I almost forgot for a second if
we leave my mic on during these video
clips and I almost said some really
horrible things about her so
I can't stand these people everything
she says there is a confusion or an
outright lie it's a government spending
problem the idea that the government if
they yes if you took all of Elon musk's
money into Peter thiel's money we'd
magically solve all these problems they
ruin absolutely everything you know rich
people they also hire a lot of people
and build a lot of stuff and innovate
and it's just nonsense but Sarah again a
certain set of people just buy this
drivel yeah and it's really sad too um
because it's people who are continually
told by people like this representative
jayapal that they are oppressed that
they can't make their own way that they
can't you know the the American dream
the reason why immigrants move here is
the idea that you know this is a
meritocracy that you can make your own
way that if you work hard you can you
can build your way up and you can become
something and you have an entire party
political party who is constantly
telling people you can't make your own
way the government has to do it for you
the government can create wealth as if
that's true and so I was listening to to
her talk and I I looked up because I
know that she's lying but I wanted to
look up the the most recent data that I
could find
um so in 2020 the IRS this is data from
the IRS shows that the top 25 percent of
earners paid nearly 89 of all income
taxes so should they keep talking about
paying their fair share like at what
what is what is fair they're already
paying 89 you want 90. you want 95 you
want the top 25 of earners to pay 100 of
all income taxes and nobody pay anything
else because guess what the three of us
know what's going to happen everyone
will be poor this headline just like
this actually enraged me it's hard to
get people think of me as even keeled
Biden to hike payments for good credit
home buyers to subsidize high-risk
mortgages listen to this home buyers
with good credit scores will soon
encounter a costly surprise a new
federal rule forcing them to pay higher
mortgage rates and fees to subsidize
people with riskier credit ratings who
are also in the market to buy houses the
fee changes will go into effect May 1st
as part of the federal Housing Finance
agency's push for affordable housing and
they will affect mortgages originating
at private Banks across the country that
pisses me the F off why am I doing this
work I mean is that not completely
bananas if you'd like more sane takes on
our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
roundtables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell